how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and
all things relating to the MCU today
we're going to be talking about a new
iteration of the Avengers team The Young
Avengers coming to the MCU now Marvel's
done a pretty good job at setting the
base and premise for the Young Avengers
to finally make their debut in fact we
pretty much know the majority of the new
young Avengers lineup that is going to
be introduced and it looks like we're
going to be seen that sooner then later
as there are reports now that the Young
Avengers project is beginning to enter
pre-development so let's talk about
everything that we know including the
lineup of The Young Avengers if you're
new be sure to subscribe to stay up to
date on all things related to the MCU
also so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 I'm
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers only five
thousand subscribers away should hit it
in a few days now you may have heard
word recently about the Young Avengers
as many different websites are talking
about it but it originally hails from
the geeks worldwide senior editor Thomas
Pulido he recently announced in a tweet
that it sounds like Marvel Studios is
gearing up to take pitches from riders
for Young Avengers now Kevin Feige has
already stated publicly that the next
five years of the MCU are already done
they know all of the movies and TV shows
that they're going to be releasing and
he even mentioned in an interview
immediately following San Diego Comic
Cons Marvel panel in 2019 that he does
know all of the characters who are going
to go on and become a part of an
Avengers team now of course we have the
New Avengers team but we also have the
Young Avengers and it sounds like they
may be coming before the New Avengers
the MCU is going to have to introduce a
few different new characters before we
can see the New Avengers come together
on the big screen however like I
mentioned for the Young Avengers we
actually have a most of the team already
revealed to us and they're all entering
the MCU pretty soon in fact some of them
already do exist in the MCU and we saw
them not too long ago in Avengers
endgame
the first one that we saw is Cassie
laying the daughter of Scott Lang aka
ant-man
and the comics she is part of the Young
Avengers as stature Cassie Lang or
stature basically has the powers of both
and
and the wasp she can grow and shrink in
size she has a helmet that helps her
communicate with over 5,000 different
species and she has wings as well that
enable her to fly now she was an
Avengers in game but her setup is most
likely going to be in ant-man 3 a recent
plot league for ant-man 3 tells us that
she's going to want to go and join the
Avengers but her father Scott and hope
don't want her to go and join so
supposedly ant-man 3 is going to be
about hope and Scott teaching Cassie how
to be a superhero they'll try to teach
her instead of her going off on her own
and fighting with the Avengers but she
wasn't the only young Avenger that was
in Avengers in game we all remember
Harley keiner
the little boy that played a major role
in Iron Man 3 he was there at the end of
Avengers in game at Tony Stark's funeral
and as we all know that is no
coincidence Marvel does everything on
purpose like I said Kevin Feige has
planned the next five years of the MCU
out so they do things way in advance but
the fact that he was at Tony Stark's
funeral probably means that he kept in
touch with him not to mention that Tony
Stark left him a lot of gear at the end
of Iron Man 3 so of course it's widely
believed that he is going to be iron lad
and the Young Avengers now Marvel is
going to have to twist the origin story
of iron lad from the comics just a
little bit to make Harley keiner
iron lad but nothing they haven't done
before we then have Kate Bishop who is
already officially confirmed to be
making an appearance in the Hawkeye
series in this series Clint is going to
be training Kate Bishop to take on the
mantle of Hawkeye and in the comics kate
bishop or hawkeye plays a major role in
The Young Avengers and since Marvel
Studios has stated that the Hawkeye
series is going to be about Kate Bishop
it's very obvious that they're preparing
her for the Young Avengers and then of
course we have Miss Marvel coming to
Disney Plus and the comics miss Marvel
is a major part of the Young Avengers
most of the time leading them this of
course is no coincidence as well again
Marvel does everything on purpose and
we're getting two new Disney plushies
both introducing very young superheroes
actually three new Disney plushies that
are going to be introducing new young
superheroes as one division is going to
introduce her twins Wiccan and speed and
of course like everybody else mentioned
they're a pretty big
part of the Young Avengers in the comics
as well so right there with everybody
that I just mentioned we have a full
Young Avengers lineup we have stature
iron lad the new Hawkeye who is going to
be Kate Bishop Miss Marvel and waken and
speed that six characters for the lineup
of the new avengers that are coming to
the MCU very soon or are already in the
MCU and it sounds like the Young
Avengers could be coming as early on as
phase five as like this report says the
writers are already being gathered to
pitch what could be the new Young
Avengers so let me know what you think
about this would you be excited for a
Young Avengers movie or perhaps a Disney
Plus show and which of the adult
Avengers would you like to see lead them
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below like the video and
don't forget to subscribe to stay
up-to-date on all the Marvel news and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof